hello and welcome to swipe from here one
of the most competitive and affluent
places on earth the city coming up
digging the digital dirt we're at a top
law firm to talk about why landing a
good job may mean taking the social out
of media on your bike the tech keeping
the Tour de France teams on the right
track pinkey power the Handy project to
increase our finger count and becoming
Batman we take on the Dark Knight in
this week's games review this week we're
at one of the country's top law firms
where we've been finding out how your
chances of landing a dream job or any
job could be seriously affected by those
recent facebook status updates
oh and don't forget those party photos
Katie Spence has been finding out why
she needs to clean up her profile page
there are some nights out which are
perhaps better forgotten but in today's
social media savvy world it's not just a
sore head you can be left struggling
with what you post online could also
leave you struggling to find a job this
year we saw about 50% of employers
report that they use social media to
review applicants for their positions
and they're looking at things like the
type of posts people are making who they
interact with online to help them make
decisions about hiring at law firms
slaughter and may technology lawyer rob
some roy advises clients on just how far
they can go when it comes to scanning
applicants social media while employers
are entitled to look at anything that's
publicly available there are guidelines
they should follow the Information
Commissioner who's the UK regulator
around the use of personal data he's put
guidelines out which aren't strictly law
but you should comply with them and
those guidelines say you know don't do a
blanket vetting of social media wait
until you've got a candidate who's some
way along the process make sure that
that candidate knows that you're going
to have that social media and that gives
them an opportunity to opt out
landing a top job in the city is no
longer about just having a good CV with
over half of employers using social
networking sites to research potential
employees it's not just what we say it
an interview that counts 43 percent of
employers now use search engines like
Google to do extra research but if
you're using social media in the right
way it can also help you secure a job
over 18 million people have now watched
marina Schifrin very public resignation
video the message to her employers went
viral and off the back of this the young
comedy writer was offered a role as a
digital content producer on a u.s. TV
show it was a gamble that paid off but
one which could have very easily killed
her career although obviously we want
people to have a personality and a life
that is going to come through on there
it also needs to be balanced with the
fact that you have other interests in a
wider scope than just going out drinking
and then partying well it's important to
have a presence online that demonstrates
your character to potential employers
how we behave on social media can mean
the difference between who's hired and
who's fired
Katie Spencer Sky News well joining me
now is Rob some Roy who you will have
seen in Katie's piece just there Rob
you're a technology lawyer and a partner
here at slaughterin make and you have
clients who scan social media for
headhunting purposes is that right yeah
that's right yeah they see the benefit
of being able to get information about
applicants through social media and
other publicly available source and
that's perfectly legal yeah I mean it
can be you know there are guidelines and
there's laws that you have to follow but
you know people like the Information
Commissioner who's the regulator around
use of personal data he gives guidelines
on how you can vet candidates and you
have to follow those guidelines but if
you do then it is perfectly legal and
what are they looking for in that
vetting process well I think it's just
the you know interesting things about
the candidate that maybe you wouldn't
see in the CV you know if the CV has
been put together by the candidate as
their story about themselves then what
they may be put out there in social
media is a bit more honesty and a bit
more truth and yeah just is that person
suitable and suited to the organisation
okay what would be on see
in terms of users which are they avoid
putting up on their Facebook pages look
I always say to them they've got to see
social media as like any other media and
imagine you were given the front page of
a national newspaper for the day and
told you know put some stuff there out
about you for people to see you'd only
want things out there that you were
proud about and that you were happy for
people to see especially you know
potential new employers so don't put
anything out there that's going to be
embarrassing what about things like
silly photos because they might be
embarrassing but it might show a
potential employer that someone's got a
good sense of humor exactly yeah and I
think there's an important message there
and I certainly say this to my clients
is you know what is it that you're
actually looking for in a social media
there's nothing wrong with a funny photo
and you know we don't want to recruit
people who are robots or automatons
they've got to have a personality so
yeah I think you know funny photos are
fine it's more extreme opinions maybe
would be something that people need to
keep under wraps and private do you
think there might be a time one day when
looking at your social media page is as
important as looking at a CV yeah I
wouldn't necessarily say as important I
mean I think the CV is the key
recruitment tool because that is the
message that the applicants is giving
out there they're answering the
questions and it's got all the important
information about them but you know as I
said earlier I think social media and
what people put out there maybe when
they're being slightly less guarded
gives you a bit more of a flavor about
their personality and what they like and
it's an important tool to use along with
the CV ok fascinating here that Rob
summary thank you thanks you're watching
spike coming up dust off your
stormtrooper outfit we're hanging out
with the gaming fanboys that this is
comic-con but first the Tour de France
there's arguably one of the most
prestigious cycling races in the world
it doesn't get much better than watching
the peloton race through some
breathtaking scenery at breakneck speeds
but it's not just the cyclists who are
working flat-out behind the scenes a
massive communications team is working
to keep things running smoothly
skies David McLean has been to the
Pyrenees to find out more in the shadow
of the Pyrenees the world's best cycling
teams prepare for a grueling 90 mile
race through the mountains the jagged
course peaks with a 2,000 meter climb
followed by a white-knuckle descent and
the athletes and their bikes must be in
peak condition high above them another
team makes last-minute adjustments to
make sure the two de France stays on
track it's something viewers take for
granted but the communications team
behind the world's biggest annual
sporting event is immense at each of the
races 21 stages hundreds of staff and
contractors have to roll out 15 miles of
cable and assemble 12 tonnes of hardware
camera crews across the course beam
their pictures to two helicopters who
fire those two planes circling above
from there it's beamed to 190 countries
around the world it's a circus we have
all these problems and we resolve in a
few minutes problems and the TV radios
don't control the problems so it's a big
challenge as well as TV coverage the
team is tasked with making sure riders
times add up across some of the world's
most challenging terrain high-speed
fiber-optic cables span the course
through which they are from 700 timing
points are fed through to a central
computer each of the six cars used by
the race officials are equipped with
Wi-Fi to communicate with each other and
the teams as they weave through isolated
mountain passes meanwhile superfast
internet connections for up to 1,000
devices is provided for the pack of
journalists following the world's most
prestigious cycling event
and you'll see themselves in public and
also for the rider these are the best
race we want to to win for the teams
behind the technology it's a tough month
at the end of each stage the equipment
is packed up within hours and driven
through the night to the finish line of
the next stage where the show starts all
over again a process that takes two
years to plan and one that's over in
seconds David McLean Sky News in the
Pyrenees your teams like coming up
pinkey power the Handy project to
increase our finger count but first for
this next item I was hoping to wear my
stormtrooper outfit unfortunately though
there's a strict dress code here and I
had to leave it outside but there's a
part of me that wishes right now I was
over in San Diego at the Comic Con
convention the Avengers age of Ultron
and Batman vs Superman might end up
getting all the headlines this weekend
at Comic Con but the video game industry
is approaching the four-day festival of
pop culture with a real vigor the
industry uses it as a launch pad for
some of the biggest releases over the
next 12 months and they pull out all the
stops
fans can zipline through Gotham City for
Batman Arkham Knight free run through an
obstacle course for Assassin's Creed
unity or even take some life-sized Mario
karts for Nintendo's latest release of
their racing sensation elsewhere there
are movie tie-ins aplenty there's the
middle-earth shadows of Mordor which
takes players on a journey set between
the events of The Hobbit and The Lord of
the Rings trilogy who can even resist
the blocky Dark Knight saga Lego Batman
3 beyond Gotham that's been launched
here this weekend as well with a very
own Adam West the original Batman of
course now most of these games haven't
been seen before in public making Comic
Con a major player and the video game
convention circuit here watching swype
coming up as the dark knight still got
it we're taking Batman on in this week's
games review but first now they say you
can tell a lot about a person from the
size of their hands I've always had very
small hands and now researchers in the
United States have come up with a gadget
which could be pretty
d for me humans were dealt a pretty good
hand when it came to evolution with two
sets of four fingers and a couple of
opposable thumbs we've come quite away
but have you ever wondered if the
arrangement could be well handy we want
to extend the synergy based control to
wearable robotic limbs researchers at
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
believe nature could do with a helping
hand they've been working on a robotic
glove that gives us two extra fingers it
has six degrees of freedom
three degrees of freedom in each finger
the fingers are quite long so the user
can grab things that are usually much
larger or much heavier than they can do
with a single hand through a clever
algorithm the robot fingers are easily
positioned in line with the human
fingers so the movement feels very
natural and intuitive if you thought
five fingers was the perfect number well
think again check out what you could do
with seven the team believed it could
help the elderly or people with
disabilities to live more independent
lives
this particular hands and or fingers you
know we can find in many other ways
we're using it and we're still exploring
you know what the kind of bono tasks
will be useful for the people for many
of us we use smartphones so frequently
it can feel like an extension of our own
bodies scientists hope that eventually
will become so comfortable with robotics
but a few extra computerized fingers
could feel like second nature jars when
sky knees you're watching sight coming
up is it game over for Batman we're
looking at the dark knights in this
week's games review but first here's a
roundup of anything you might have
missed this week Facebook shares hit a
new record high this week after it
posted a profits growth of a hundred and
thirty seven percent for its last
quarter the world's largest internet
social network now counts one point
three two billion users per month
meanwhile profits that Microsoft have
taken a hit after the company's
acquisition of Nokia the technology
giant made 2.7 billion pounds in the
three months to the end of June a 7%
fall on the same period last year
in stark contrast strong iPhone
sales have helped apple to a bumper
quarter the company made a profit of 4.5
billion pounds a 12 percent improvement
compared to last year more than 35
million iPhones were sold
however iPad sales fell for the second
quarter in a row I think it's less of a
status symbol than phones actually your
phones are quite publicly sticking them
on the table everyone can see if you've
got the fingerprint scanner and if you
care about that kind of thing then you
will want the latest whereas I think
once people have an iPad they're not so
desperate to replace it every one or two
years while we're talking gadgets a tiny
device which links to your smartphone
has been developed to let you know if
your drink has been spiked and what it's
been laced with the PD ID which can fit
on your keyring users tech already used
by America's Drug Enforcement Agency
simply dip wait a few seconds and you
will know if your drink has been drugged
once immersed the PD ID takes three
different tests to identify the drink
and its components developer David
Wilson has put it on two crowdfunding
website indiegogo to try and raise
enough cash to get it mass-produced it
seems it's a man's world if you're
working at Twitter new figures released
by the company show that the social
media site is mostly staffed by men the
tech industry is coming for a lot of
stick just recently for not being
diverse enough the data shows overall
only 30 percent of Twitter staff a
female and a supermarket in
Staffordshire is going to be the first
to be powered by rotten food
Sainsbury's has revealed its super
self-sufficient plans to create its own
electricity generated from biogas
apparently food from the store which
can't be given away or resold as animal
feed is going to be poured into an
anaerobic digester the electricity
generated from methane that's given off
will then be piped back into the store
don't worry though I'm reliably informed
you won't be able to smell it well fans
now have to wait until 2015 for the next
generation Batman game so is the third
in Rock Steady's trilogy worth the wait
Ross Thomason has been taking a look
Batman Arkham Knight isn't due out until
2015 but it's the fourth game over
recent years of a Batman franchise but
it's the third game from Rocksteady so
this is the one that probably is going
to end the trilogy and the one that
people are really waiting for it's gonna
you're gonna be available on Xbox one
Playstation 4 and PC so it's a next
generation game third-person style game
very similar in ways of how the previous
two games have played so it's up to you
as Batman to go around Gotham City and
save the day from all of these criminals
there Allen it looks fantastic expansive
or beyond anything else you've seen in
one of these games before it's truly
going to hopefully end this story in
this journey for Batman I'm sure there's
more announcements to come over the
coming months before its release in
early 2015 if you double the previous
Batman games this will have everything
plus more so I highly recommend getting
college bit when it does come out the
next game is Disney infinity 2.0 Marvel
Super Heroes you get three toys in the
starter pack which you can then place on
this cool base that as soon as you place
it on there they turn up on your screen
in the actual game the likes of Iron Man
Captain America Hulk Black Widow and
they come up on the screen and you get
them to play through different
adventures in different areas of the
Marvel Universe
people can go on build their own levels
playsets and then upload them online so
to let everyone around the world play
them limitless really to a point of how
much gameplay you can get out of this
with it being Marvel set with Avengers
with I would expect plenty of new
characters that come post-launch
huge success written all over so the
next game is Lego Batman 3 it's the
third of the Batman games but there's
been plenty of other Lego games within
these franchises and this time Lego
Batman is going into space so Brainiac
has stolen the Lantern ring and he's
basically shrinking universities across
the galaxy so it's up to you as Batman
and all of the other DC characters to go
after him and basically save the
universe it's great that it's not set
within the Gotham City you're gonna get
exactly the same experience you would
get from any Lego game so it's all about
smashing things up collecting as many
coins as you can the replayability with
all of the different characters says
around 150 characters you'll be able to
unlock in this game your suit looks
really good is all I'm saying one hero
to another it's really working for you
sorry right brooding carry on they're
hugely addictive these games are really
for any age group doesn't matter whether
you're a child a teenager an adult you
will always love this there's a great
co-op capability as well so you can
split screen and play together with
friends the flag of franchise goes from
strength to strength and Batman 3 beyond
Gotham will be a huge successful and
later on this year the last game is Star
Wars Battlefront you start as either on
the rebel side or the Empire and that we
set in key areas from the whole Star
Wars world as well so you could be on
Hoth in the real ice cold world of being
on speeder bikes or students land
speeders ATS T's if you're on the
Empire's side and it's all about taking
over the map again this has got so much
potential because it's been quite a long
time since the last one came out and
they've gone back to the Lucas ranch
they've gone to see all of the original
models that were made for the original
films plus they will probably release
this in line with the new film so next
year or 2015 could be a huge year for
Star Wars
it looks from what we see in which is
only a very small amount truly amazing
again don't know exactly when it's
coming but I'm sure we'll see more and
more of this over time and yeah I'm very
much excited for this thanks Ross that's
it for this week don't forget you can
catch up with all the breaking tech
stories all week on sky knees for iPad
our smartphone apps are sky nice calm
see you next time bye bye